good morning Millennials it is a
beautiful sunny bright and happy
Wednesday here in New York City and I am
NOT hungover but not too warm you know
it's a it's a cool 60 I was gonna wear a
jean shorts but then I put on jeans and
like honestly having drinks and then not
being hungover is amazing you know best
of both was in bed by 1:00 so I got like
six seven hours of sleep so like I'm
good which is fine I'm good enough for
that's more than enough for most people
and I'm just feeling so happy to be
alive it's an amazing show as always
Jackie and I are more than happy to
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know before you take a bite out
of your morning toast and then we are
going to be joined by really like some
what I'm really excited about so excited
about Vinny Guadagnino also known as
Vinny G from the Jersey Shore the cuido
the key to me to go will be joining us
and you have questions for him about
Miami about Quito about whatever make
sure to drop a comment on Instagram I
mean on Facebook or on YouTube and we
will do our best together to him he'll
be joining us a little bit later on in
the show so relax have a drink take seed
go get coffee talk to Sally from the
water cooler no stay here stay here let
it out no we bring your phone with you
to the water cool oh yeah okay I'd like
get headphone splitter so you can sound
like a park together
oh my god I'm just dead but like alive I
cannot believe my shows are tomorrow
like starting like I just want to let
you know like I'm really amber Baird um
do you want to prepare a little bit now
like you want to work through some ideas
okay sure so like I don't know like it's
so awkward to do stand out because it's
like fake like you have a routine I
completely agree
when stand-up is like marketed as this
like off the cuff like comic LA and it's
like not you like fake it and like and
you have to like fake like we didn't he
just stand up oh you should we go on
tangents all day on the show but like
you have to plan your tangents first and
up which is just go crazy up to plunge
in it should be plangent comedy and like
for my first two shows I Caroline took
the first one felt so good and like
authentic and then like the second time
I was like I am a fraud and I knew that
there were like some people I know a lot
of Harris about tickets to both show
it's like I'm like a lot of Harris knows
that I'm like like I felt like a fraud
okay but every comedian does that like
you're in the same boat as Kevin Hart
yes Schumer so let your memories by the
way I ever really started to like brand
myself as a comedian how's that guy like
do you like it cuz I remember you are
comic
yeah right and so last night I was out
with some friends and like this guy came
over who like
new one of the people in my party and he
ends up like sitting down for a while
and he's like a director he was like
what do you do when I was like I just
had it I was like I am Comique and he
was like I'm like I'm a comedian
I know he was like because Kade was
saying something about my shows and he
was like what kind of shows and I was
like stand up he said oh you're comedian
and I was like yes and he was like
that's awesome like where do you before
him and like caroline's it's very
prestigious so was like caroline's
and he's in Nashville which by the way I
asked LC Ballerini she's like it's very
legit she's up Chris Rock there oh my I
was looking at their Wikipedia it's rich
in history yeah so I just wanted like we
did a knees or xanies I mean for us it's
probably zannies but daddies is what
people call Lots annexes I feel you want
to pop a couple zannies I love it even
more we're going to Danny's with a
couple's Inez I'm gonna house aliens
aliens I'm gonna have a zani after that
II knew - oh hi I'm so excited I can't
wait for zan we announced yesterday that
our Nashville live show would be June 6
Nashville International back of CMA fest
it is sold out we're so excited to see
everyone there and I'm so excited like
we don't have like a pit about like
selling the tickets like it's done you
know Damien totally and it was like a
full day cycle right and it's a new day
and I'm so relieved in it and I don't
know why it just I feel like it's not
gonna be as pit worthy is like other
things that we've done have been well so
I don't be the forum pits our first ever
live show I like knots and I don't even
know why we do this like yeah I mean
it's different asleep but like I had not
a pit in the world because like doing it
with someone else is a dream compared to
doing oh my god like it's so fun like
and we have like the template of the
stories and the like the show pretty
much write writes itself so like it's
not the same when you're a one-woman
show on broad right but you know that is
a life I chose for myself and it is the
life I will continue to lead and you
can't like you can you have to do it in
order to say you have a one-woman show
on Broadway so if you race you have to
pay if you're watching right now and you
do have a ticket here's what I ask of
you as an audience member just like
laughs like your life demand one's
watching just laughs laughs laughs
laughs laughs first of all saying I'll
have a lot of drinks cause like that'll
just help the overall morale in the show
and third of all just have a good time
totally I'm so excited and I'm looking
forward to preparing something a little
because the first time I watched it like
I totally got what you mean it's so
weird to hear a planned joke yeah and
there's a lot of people who were there
both times we're so not planners
especially not you because you don't
even have a I don't have a planner um
but I'm so excited for some new material
it's my favorite show on Broadway and
you guys know I don't even like Broadway
okay I'm ready are you ready to jump
right into the fast five stories you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toes
completely completely okay it's a very
Taylor Swift heavy day because she
started her tour last night not without
a gift from Katy Perry bad blood no more
asks TMZ Taylor Swift and Katy Perry's
long-standing feud is apparently water
under the bridge but it does not
involved in this right because ke sent a
literal olive branch and it looks like
Taylor accepted Taylor posted a short
video showing off a gift she got from
Perry with the caption Thank You Katy
and some heart emojis it's actually one
emoji with two hearts and she said she
said this means a lot to me she vocally
said that and of course the the toasters
being this loose that they are read the
note that Katy Center which said hey old
friend oh yes I have been doing some
reflecting on past miscommunications and
hurt feelings between us I really want
to clear the air it goes on to say that
Katy is deeply sorry about something but
part of the letter was covered by the
olive branch very meticulously by by one
Taylor's well I'm sure but you know what
I'm so here for this like the suit is
not only ancient tales old it's time but
like the genesis of it wasn't even like
it's over backup dancers so I don't know
five years over backup dancers does not
if you'd make no I totally agree it was
over John Mayer I would understand oh
right I thought it was so great together
and just talked about John Mayer and how
he never fulfilled them because he's a
eternal bachelor it's like as much as I
wanted to eat John Mayer I know he would
only break my heart so like what's the
point what's the point but like honestly
the point is just to experience making
love to John Mayer and like that's well
you can do that without dating him and
if that's all you want for a minute and
he can't break your heart cuz your
heart's not but it's not all I want for
him like I want an emotional connection
and I want to live in Montana with him
oh so it's like a Nikki Bella John Cena
situation exactly like you I just can't
get him to commit it's a Karel Adam
situations
um anyways my theory is so that like
Katy Perry went to the Met Gala was with
the kardashians who they've been getting
along like the enemy of my enemy is my
friend
and so Katy and the Kardashians have
been good North went to the Katy Perry
concert but I feel like something
happened at the Met Gala which prompted
Katy to send an olive branch to tell her
the next day
switching alliances yeah it's it's odd
timing I would say it not because it's
the beginning of her tour so I don't
know is it that or is it the Met Gala
who knows but like obviously Katy was
the one time like extend the olive
branch like Taylor would never never
also what Taylor did to Katy Perry like
I think of all the things that that have
gone down the meanest thing that she did
was release her whole catalogue of music
to Spotify on the day that Katy Perry's
album got released because everyone was
so excited to listen to Taylor Swift
like Katy Perry's out oh my god she did
that yes so Taylor released her music
back on Spotify after years of not being
on Spotify I'm on the same day that Katy
Perry's album got released which is just
like business cruelty no totally but
like I don't think that that album was
gonna be like a hit maker regardless no
but like someone like me for example who
is a fan of Katy Perry's music and gives
new music Fridays a chance every Friday
when I saw I would have listened to Katy
Perry's album that day but I never
listened to it because I listened to the
towers of catalogue and if I listened to
your album on music new music Friday I'm
never listening to it but also side note
um Taylor Swift being back on Spotify
has just like really enhanced my life my
entire life like in so many positive
ways and it's like if you never if
you're in it sometimes with music it's
like you're having abundance of music
and you can't even pick what to listen
to but sometimes there's a drought yeah
and in those situations where you don't
know what to listen to Taylor Swift
always works
always always supplies she's always
pertinent to the situation
there's so many cameras I'm just like
yeah and also like I see Jackie's
getting some close-ups like a money I
just wanna make sure I'm covered or
maybe this is my camera and that's your
camera I am how do I look okay Jacob
says I look like
also psi we need the toasters to leave
Jacob alone like there guys Jacobs and I
you guys he has a girlfriend like a limo
okay Jacob has a girlfriend they are
very happy and cute together we just got
a dog we saw them at the greatest 21st
they just got a dog like it's serious
it's very serious and yeah but he's
great guy um Katy Perry Taylor Swift put
Tibetan totally but like is it it's such
a tangled web of lies like between
everyone and you know like I don't know
it's just like if I was Katy Perry like
this is the thing I stand Taylor I'm
totally her friend but like I'm just
like I'm looking at it for like a third
party like if I was Katy Perry like what
I want to be jealous was friend like
there's no way this feud would have
ended if Katy Perry wasn't the bigger
person you know what I mean yeah because
I feel like Taylor just feels like the
victim like she won't reach out like I
feel like she thinks the whole world has
turned on her she can't like rise up
above it because she's in the situation
like because of all our sides - from
like Hollywood yeah but she doesn't have
that crewmen anymore she's not friends
with any of those girls anymore I was
thinking for he's not so [ __ ] extra
about it thank God no but like she's not
friends with Carly anymore and that
really broke the whole like the
foundation and I don't think like I
don't know this is a survive that I get
I don't think Ryan Reynolds like liked
him and like being like putting that
basket of like squad you know what I
mean of big loser
yellow-bellied loser like some people
need a squad like Lena Dunham like the
squad Martha hunt took this quad really
gave them like Seinfeld
gratata she's happy now he had an Oscar
nominee but like I don't know I just
think like everyone's kind of over it
and I really don't think I don't think
her and Celine are friends anymore
I mean it's so childish what she was
doing and like even as the squad was
happening and it's so crazy because I
was watching the squad I'm like this is
lame as hell but then like the media is
like tell us girls guys everything you
needed anymore
like no one needed it yeah and it should
dissolve and if you're gonna hang out
with your friends just hang out with
your friends and don't like
be freaks Patton totally and this is
like Taylor's thing like she pulls the
woman card like all the time to the
point that where it's like it's working
against us as a gender totally like you
can be a feminist and you can like have
female friends and empower one another
without being annoying about it totally
however to our credit the old Taylor
can't come to the phone right now
because she's ahead and so the new
Taylor hasn't done these things yeah so
I'm only basing my life from here on out
off of the new Taylor okay speaking of
the new Taylor I'm gonna skip to our
third story just for continuity like
because Taylor Swift like we said first
stadium tour last night University of
Phoenix Stadium in Glendale I saw in her
stock Glendale how do we oh you went to
go on now didn't know you were discussed
oh yeah
I know Glendale anyways I'm gonna blend
though cuz it sounds like the place in
Riverdale Greendale okay yeah maybe and
like I don't know everything happens in
Glendale I guess okay Taylor Swift
called out Kim Kardashian for bullying
during her show last night Taylor Swift
and Katy Perry's feud might be done in
dusted but the pop stars Kardashian is
nowhere near over as the morning 2 was
reported like I when we saw that
Instagram story I was like you don't
have screen recording capabilities no I
had the iPhone 7 with Io spoof not
screen recording okay she had it it's
awesome no I want it but I just feel
like there's a certain like I just I
have to get the new phone order I got
the new iOS you can update your phone
and just get it but sometimes the newest
updates they break your phone yes that's
very true
if Apple wants you to get a new phone
they think Apple once we get true
Taylor kicked up her reputation world
tour on Tuesday night and chatted to the
audience about the low point in her life
when Kim Kardashian exposed her on
snapchat on national snake day wait
Jackie people know why you know Glendale
it's like a famous keeping up with the
Kardashian side Kourtney's like this is
Glendale no I'm sorry
what about it snowing [ __ ] willows mad
I know and your scissors going to yeah
we need to talk about that in a second
personals get through this story a
couple years ago Taylor said when
someone called me a snake on social
media and it caught on and then a lot of
people called me a lot of things on
social media teller said and I went
through some really low times for a
while because of it I went through some
times when I didn't know if I was gonna
get to do this anymore and I guess the
snakes I wanted to send a message to you
guys that if someone uses name-calling
to bully you on social media and even if
a lot of people jump on board with it
that doesn't have to be you it can
strengthen you instead and what she
performed long live here's the thing
what we know about Taylor Swift like and
we know this to be true it was like
she's super calculated everything she
does is like a move strategic it's PR
but this Kim thing was so unexpected
and it threw flute through her through
her flew her through a loop it through
internet through through through through
her through a loop it's go through the
way that's like a weird birth or a loop
through it through me through a loop is
there me for a loop no no it threw her
through a loop
I feel like they would ever notice this
whole time like if that phrase was weird
it's through her through a loop yes but
two different spellings of through no I
understand but like the the double thumb
is odd it threw her for a loop for loop
people are I thought it was flew her
through a loop no that sounds right
threw her for a loop okay it really
rocked her world rocked your world
because like she's like been this person
for so long who like everything every
article that comes out about her like
even if it's good or bad she had
something to do with it like she's that
powerful and for something like this
happened that totally confirmed what
everyone thought about her as a segment
ability of shrew friends reference I
don't think she'll ever get over like
her feud with Kim will never even if Kim
apologized like it would never settle
because like to what in I know how
Taylor Swift things and in her mind what
can fit did it's like the most
unforgivable I agree and I don't think
Taylor will ever forget like the
feelings that she had like that day and
I'm sure like in her mind like she has
plotted like the death of Kim Kardashian
you know like so even if they be she's
involved in Paris like I wonder what her
like thoughts were actually I don't
think she was pleased about it because
it made Kim even like more and more that
account yeah and like everyone just
loves her even more now totally but even
if they patched things up which I'm sure
eventually they will because you know
the news has to move on she'll never
forget hashtag never forget no no like
I'm like I'm I feel like I kind of
understand that we Taylor's for things
and like I get how devastating this
history yeah and it was her like she's
fine now
yeah sort of like it's like we still are
always talking about it you know yeah
anybody feel like in the process of
rebuilding herself she's not like
rebuilt you know when like the wire in
your bra snaps and then like the wire
like it starts digging into your boob I
don't know about a snapping but I know
about a digging good digging lucky ask
me right are you not good guests do you
still support okay what else um Colton
Hayes files from for divorce from Jeff
Leatham which is really actually the
only been married for what six months
yes so call
he's and Jeff Leatham he's kind of um
that's like a tongue twister of them are
like Ruth's Chris Steakhouse Ruth Chris
is know Ruth Ruth that's Chris that
please confuses me it sounds like
breezes chain or is it prestigious or is
those that's crazy
it's literally the best restaurant like
I've never been Jackie its weight so the
most prized remember that Miley used to
go like in her heyday with like Mandy
and like that guy Justin that she was
dating yeah well she was always fat at
me and Ben there's not there's only one
in the city and it's like not popular at
all it's like much more of a West Coast
thing I think and when me and Ben more
important where you go we were sitting
at our hotel then had a steak house in
the lobby and we're like Ruth is Chris
we thought was a Puerto Rican where the
police say you know how do we go and it
was unbelievable like Ben had his
halibut and I had a set like it was so
good we get home we're telling everyone
about this indigenous steakhouse to
Puerto Rico please say and they're like
roots Chris you know it's like if they
have one literally on every corner and
we're like what we're like no way and
they were like yeah like it's legit like
a like a TGI Fridays cpk and we're like
but the indigenous halibut like we were
like we were shocked and embarrassed and
now we go all the time
to the one in New York no but like when
we travel to go into the one in Orlando
we oh when we went to the one in New
Orleans like every time we're in like it
oh is that where it started it started
in New Orleans says Jacob so like all
the time it's so yes like in New York
you don't go there like millions of
restaurants but when you're in like a
foreign city it's just like Ruth's Chris
brings you home okay they're headed to
splits he'll get to Ruth's Chris from
jet Lisa Lisa it's a tongue twister and
it's clear who pulled the plug on her
relationship because Colton has filed
for divorce so it doesn't always mean by
the way and by the way Jeff's richer so
like and when I read Brandi Glanville's
book like she said that she didn't filed
for divorce because her girlfriend told
her not to cuz you have to pay a fee and
in hindsight she wishes that she had
done in and just paid the fee because
like that sense of like yeah I finished
your book cause it started to get really
repetitive but that's something that I
got out of it that you have to pay a fee
to file for divorce
that's shocking shocking so who's the
richer one Jeff yes Jeff is the day's
no no open days empty days is the poem
he's the flower but an empty vase is the
poem that the waiter wrote about Monica
and she didn't get that he was calling
her like ugly and vapid but open vase
what's his company called know maybe
it's empty vase okay will TV know it's
bothering me Jacob was on the case and
Colton is that Teen Wolf money so I
think they're both okay but yet like by
the way who the hell was Colton hands he
okay he looks so much different but I'm
pretty sure he was on Teen Wolf and then
I'm pretty sure he dressed up as Shrek
one year for Halloween
no not correct that's how I know I'm
also the mean lady from under the sea oh
earth Allah Ursula but no yeah but
what's a company called I follow him on
Instagram everyone okay now I have to
hug it out but I know that Colton he's
dressed up as Shrek one year and like
went full out and green and I guess he
must have done earth slow the next year
he must be big on Halloween that's
literally a makeup artist because he did
that no he's just like a big Halloween
guy just like me I'm a big Halloween guy
I want to go as Shrek and Fiona one year
but like I need to get a good makeup
artist okay
yeah Jeff Leatham rebranded - Jeff
Leatham florists used to be called
you'll find it the Teen Wolf star filed
Docs to say in Los Angeles just six
months after he married Jeff last
October in a star-studded wedding in
Palm Springs officiated by Kris Jenner
herself
TMZ broke the story called him and Jeff
broke up just last week Colton later
tweeted quote Jeff would never cheat he
is an amazing man please stop being mean
to him it was a stunning move following
Jeff's extravagant proposal in Cabo that
included help from cher as we reported
Jeff proposed in March 2017 and just
four days after their engagement they're
already talking about kids update 335
p.m. Pacific time
TMZ has obtained Colton's divorce stocks
which don't list his and Jeff state of
separation for now but do cite a wreck
American sizeable differences he's
asking a judge to terminate spousal
support for both of them he also signals
each will pay his own attorneys fees
okay this is just so upsetting because
their engagement was beautiful like so
epic on the beach fireworks it's just
beautiful then Kris Jenner married them
like it doesn't get any better than that
and it's like how could you do this to
Chris you guys I know she might be so
embarrassed happy
her first and last wedding now okay so
look I'm really trying to set up two
people and like I really want them to
get married because I want to like
officiate it oh but they haven't spoken
yet I wouldn't want to officiate you
have to be on your feet and you have to
like prepare and I just want to enjoy
the wedding and dance the night away
well you can enjoy it but literally it's
so easy this is how I would do it
welcome [ __ ] thank you for gathering
here today to celebrate the love and
light of Jackie and Doc and why are you
trying to set up I don't want to say
it's like I don't embarrass okay can you
name one of the people no it's to really
like fun
powerful cute like well-off like
successful in their job men and I just
think they're perfect for each other
okay and I'll two and one of them is
gonna guess on the show that's what I'll
say oh I think I know well I'll tell you
later
okay okay I mean okay okay
anyways I just I'm upset about this no
I'm upset about it too and like and like
six months like yeah this is like really
it's bad and it's like you know it was
bad from the beginning then and they
just like look I'd rather I prefer 72
day marriage but yeah I'm married but
what could have happened in the six
months like what did you find out if I
thought about the person that you didn't
know while dating them like the only
thing that really makes sense is like
cheating because but I don't I don't
think that's it because I think the
person would have cheated before the
marriage I don't I mean I don't know I
don't know it's just and attracted me
chief and you know II mean what's
annoying is that like we'll probably
never find out you know that is annoying
it's like um I'm of two minds on this
because I feel like as celebrities like
you profit off of making your lives
public and having the public consume
your life so like this is the life you
chose so if you're gonna show us the
proposal on the wedding you should also
show us the divorce I completely agree
on the other hand I think that like
people aren't titled to their privacy
especially celebrities like everyone and
you know we do consume it's our
entertainment we're getting something
out of it we don't deserve everything
from them so I don't know how to feel
about it and I think having experience
like a somewhat invasion of privacy I am
now of the mindset like yes this is what
we signed up for but like know where to
draw the line yeah and like some things
can remain private like once you give
everything to the public it's like the
public's no longer interested in you
know they're like done with you like
they had sex with you and like there
a younger woman leave something to the
imagination as Carol would say to
Tinsley about her relationship with
Scott are you cut up on Maroni
yes I need to talk about hints Lane
Scott I need look to Brenda she's really
like spiraling I'm so pretty was it on
last night no what time tonight so let's
make half of tomorrow okay but I just
caught up with it yesterday and like
Tinsley and Scott are perfect for each
other and I'm obsessive them they're
like two middle schoolers she put up a
picture of them on her Instagram and
then deleted it like what does that mean
maybe she just looked bad or there was
obvious taste I didn't think anything I
don't I wouldn't think anything of it
okay next happened splitsville news oh
so much spit splitsville these days so
much what's that like it's splitsville
population 1,000 no it's splitsville
population john cena Nikki Bella and
Jeff Leake them and Colton Haynes Nikki
Bella may be living at her sister brie
Bella's house but she is still quote
spending nights with ex-fiance John Cena
at his apartment a source exclusively
tells Us Weekly honestly this makes me
happy
no joke Nikki hasn't moved out of John's
apartment even though she very much
wanted to after the wedding was called
off the source tells us adding that Tina
quote doesn't want her to have to deal
with moving after everything that
they've been through as a couple very
kind because moving is probably the
worst thing second to bridge before your
wedding
Nikki revealed to me YouTube video on
Tuesday that she was staying with brie
and her husband Bryan quote had kind of
been mi a I've kind of been hiding out
they told me the star told fans in the
video I wanted to reach out to you all
and thank you all for your love and
support I can't tell you how much it's
meant to me especially through a
difficult time so yeah she's still
sleeping with John Cena and like no but
is she sleeping with John Cena or at
Regina's apartment without John Cena
spending nights with John Cena at his
apartment good honestly look I really
want them to get back I want to get back
together and okay so marriage wasn't the
right Avenue for them but like can't we
figure out a way to make this work like
they need to sit down with like a
negotiator no a mediator okay so look
he's like he doesn't want to have kids
or get married and she wants both so
let's do one maybe they shouldn't get
married maybe they should just have kids
and like be in a civil court chip
whatever it's well um domestic
no way it's called that I remember from
Allen Gregory he says when you're like
roommates with someone and then like for
ten years and then you're marry like a
partner what's it called domestic
partner a domestic partner no there's
another word I have to really watch out
and Gregory oh nice comment if you've
ever seen Alan create just a thing me
and Jackie accidentally fell it was a
comedy starring Jonah Hill Barry shows
the cartoon as a cartoon on a cartoon
comedy starring Jonah Hill one season
and he looks like eleven-year-old like
billionaire a common-law marriage oh
that's what it is yo give it 10 years
you're in a common-law marriage
congratulations you got what you wanted
and hopefully have some or a civil union
yes all the same thing I believe justice
for Allen guys yeah I actually recently
watched the pilot again it was
absolutely hysterical
he's like 11 years old but he's really
like a 90 year old man at heart and he's
a billionaire and he's like two gay dads
who are like literally like worship the
ground he walks on and he like has to go
to public school he's been homeschooled
his whole life but they want him to go
to regular school anybody falls in love
with the principal it's so funny and
like it's just so good it's okay you
guys like if you're really bored at work
saying like Sally's ooo definitely buy
an episode on Amazon and enjoy Nicky and
John please you guys do it for us you
know for the toasters
if Nikki and John or someone you know is
watching this here's a message like
seriously like we're rooting for you
like whatever you need from us to get
back together like we can do like
whether that's just like public support
or just like we're like not talking
about it at all I'm giving you a nice
privacy like living normal lives we'll
pretend like you guys don't exist as
long as you're together yeah it's just
like I know it'd make you happy would
make us happy and it's like there's
literally no reason not to or like if
you need Nikki Bella like more Instagram
followers so yeah like you're more like
on John Cena's level or like you need
more people to watch their show like
will tell people to do this okay this is
the thing like when people break up and
it's like so difficult like so why are
you breaking up do you know any new
totally no it's like I get to people
definitely break up for different
reasons like if someone cheats I like I
got it but like if both parties like
they broke up for like different just
having different views of life and like
it's so painful to be without one
another like you're obviously meant to
be together get back together yeah like
you both love each other you both want
to be together you both are good people
shouldn't we be able to make it work
here guys like masochism however then
it's like yeah they have different views
on life so in the short term yes it's
easier to be together but in the long
term if she you know
wakes of it sixty years old and doesn't
have children and just
resent John for the rest of her life
that's right true huh I don't know
relationships are hard you guys
especially when you don't know the
people and you just have to talk about
the things that you read on Us Weekly
really hard really really hard but I
think we do a good job let's go
okay last story speaking of
relationships you guys so as everyone
knows dj khaled infamously said that he
does not go down on his wife Dwayne the
rock Johnson has a TMI response to DJ
Khaled's controversial oral sex comments
stop like really like I don't talk about
this yet this is what Dwayne Johnson
said
ahem clears throat as a man I take great
pride in mastering all performances this
is probably a little TMI
I will now quietly excuse myself from
this fun thread well honestly that's a
great response because like for his kid
followers like they don't get it they
think he's mastering like a roll of
acting or whatever wait let's let's
start from the beginning because we
never initially reported on the story
because it happened over the weekend
geez Khalid went on a radio show and
said that he doesn't perform oral sex on
his wife but she has to do it to him
because he's a king and needs to end
quote there's different rules for men
okay first of all like this is an
incredibly [ __ ] up like misogynistic
thing to say and like his life won't
change because of it because he's a man
and that's just what happens when you're
a man you could say [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
even in your ripe old age like no even
in 28 yeah like so nothing's gonna
happen but like we can talk about it for
fun and this is the thing like teaching
lets wife puts up with so much you see
that video for snapping don't even work
out you mean did I put on my answer him
you know what's that yeah it was so
funny and like honestly like definitely
she gets a lot of perks from like being
DJ he's very wealthy like but like I
don't know if the pros outweigh the cons
like he seems like so annoying do you
know anything like
snapchatting everything like and i cuz
she calls him college like shut up
she's so fleet it's commas first name or
last name last name what's his first
name
Jacob I'll find out DJ first name D
middle name Jay last name Khalid okay so
far so Cal's his first you know he's
Khaled Khaled Khaled that's cool
yeah Khaled Khaled like Lauren Lauren
Lauren Bush married Ralph Lauren son
David Lauren Lauren Lauren Lauren Bush
married to Ralph Lauren son David
Lawrence she's acting thornbush Lauren
and she probably goes by that cuz like
Lauren Lauren it's great
or it's Lawren Laurette but also what
yeah yeah yeah that's cute
okay wait I won't talk I'm gonna go back
to did you know it's like Phillip
Phillips you guys you guys just it's for
Phillip Phillips he's an incredible
artist I completely agree
hey my so McGraw need to go on tour
together and get me a front row seat in
back seat me when he opened up for John
Mayer
and it was beautiful like I love going
to concerts where I'm just excited to
see the opener as I am for the headline
that's so rare I feel like her me it's
it's not that rare like I'm really
Little Mix
open for ariana grande and I was no I
mean that's amazing I'm looking I saw
five sauce open up for one direction it
is probably the best night of my whole
life I saw at Kelsea Ballerini and Bret
young open up for Lady Antebellum
unbelievable I saw Mary Mars yeah but
they were equals yeah who else I don't
know I can't remember um
so back to the see Jake Howell thing she
puts up with a lot and like I don't know
I feel like she might be at her breaking
point
do you know any me I would be honest and
now she's like being publicly
embarrassed I agree I feel like she is
really private cuz for so long I didn't
even know that he had a wife and a baby
yeah no he's she's super private and
honestly good for her um I think she
might this might be the straw that broke
the Colin's back oh that's good I like
that just a little early morning
wordplay I are you a horse
sure naysayer oh okay um dj khaled man I
don't know some of the Weight Watchers
is a detail that spokesperson for
Watchers is that true yeah but it
doesn't look like he's losing weight no
told he needs to cope he never loses on
keto it's oh speaking of let's move on
because I really want to get to Vinny I
so much to tell him and I really need to
yell at him for making a monster out of
him before we cut to break for Benny I
want to just we cut benefits quickly did
you watch him the reunion part one was
like heavy like honestly I really was
crying when Jacques crying it was so sad
and everyone was coming hard for scheana
like huh and like almost like she
doesn't really deserve it cuz this is
the thing like what you can say about
scheana is like she's a little annoying
and like not self-aware it looks likes
just self-centered but she's
mien and I thought everyone was being
like like really like ganging up on her
and like I might want to defend her but
I really kind of felt bad for her I did
feel bad for I felt like people were
just kind of like piling it on her even
like if someone had a specific issue
with her then like everybody goes in
about it I don't feel like she's not
she's at I feel like she is a good
person yeah then I feel like she
sometimes like enjoys other people like
being downbeat yeah but you know what I
couldn't really understand why her and
Lala weren't friends they didn't say a
reason why it's cuz it's like Lala
thought like Sheena didn't text her much
wow that's not a reason to meet someone
yeah I don't know it's confusing also
the reunion was like mayhem like you and
II couldn't control them there's so many
of you think it's like they're asking
each other questions and talking over
each other and like any like honestly
didn't like even need to be there and
then when Lisa was like give Lala your
your cards because Lala was like asking
better questions than he was I want to
talk about Lisa and Tom Tom because I
feel like this is the first time I man
our morals that we're seeing like the
the manipulating Lisa Vanderpump that we
see on Beverly Hills because she hasn't
cashed their text and like I'm the one
hand it's like oh that's nice that she's
not gonna like make them pay for their
equity like she should be paying them to
use their name completely and I'm like
worried that she's not gonna give them a
[ __ ] their due diligence and like this
is this is where the show gets confusing
because like it's almost like the
bachelor like we're not done like we
know that all the cast members like have
a lot of money and like our super famous
and like they're almost superseding like
Lisa's level like they they're she's not
their mom anymore like she's not their
boss like they can really do whatever
they want and like then now being
partners it's like even more like
they're really equals yes and no they
don't know how to like to start a
restaurant but I'm just saying like in
terms of the world the world yeah yes I
agree and there needs to be like I wish
they had signed a contract because Tom
Tom like is gonna be another CERN
another pump and like if they don't get
a piece of that like that's [ __ ] oh
and there's been so much like promotion
of Tom Tom on the show and I think by
the way I totally forgot that she didn't
give it like a hammering contract I
think if Guillermo contract like that's
my business
ng I was a freak jerem Oh like he's
little creepy yeah
that just like really pissed me off but
I hope I want people to like stand up to
Lisa okay I understand why they like I'm
deferens short certainly she definitely
changed their lives and like she is a
wise older woman and she gives them good
advice but like she also metals and is
like not nice to them and like
continuing to call them a junior partner
yeah and by the way a restaurant I mean
I know nothing about the bar but
industry but it does not need to cost
two and a half million dollars no that's
quite could've cost a million and then
they're each putting in what is hundred
okay and they each own 10% and I think
that that would be fair I totally agree
and another thing about the reunion it's
like I really feel like a million types
of ways about Ariana like I don't really
know like I think she's really mean but
also like really sympathetic sometimes
and like I don't know like sometimes I
feel like she has like a soft spot for
sauce to eat she's like really nice turn
then she says like some really horrible
like mean things about saucy and like I
don't know like I think Gavin Jamie yeah
damaging and like I watch and I'm like I
hate you
yeah I kind of like you it's I think
that's how sassy feels too and that's I
never like so on and off also I just
wasn't feeling Andy during the reunion I
thought his questions were like so when
when he asks when he's talking about
Stassi and Patrick which was like
shocking and like to hear her talk about
how like she doesn't even recognize
herself and like yes four years of your
life I was like so crazy you look wasn't
and he's like trying to draw parallels
between Ariana's abusive relationship
and stassi's and it's like not all
relationships are the say yeah and like
it would a Mamie a little like
uncomfortable yeah no nothing really
happened except for like scheana getting
up and walking away and saying that this
was worse than her divorce oh but I did
like scheana she said one thing and she
was like I felt really bad because I I
was like so obsessed with Rob that I
threw Shay under the bus and like Shay
like always took my side like Rob was
like talking so much [ __ ] about scheana
like which really wasn't cool to like
her friends on the show and like even
though really she like threw
Shay under the bus put his addiction out
there like he always defended her like
he never went and shot scenes with Tom
and being like she was being a bit and
he like never faulted her her being on
the show yeah so like I actually really
liked that she acknowledged that I
thought it was really like the right
thing to do and [ __ ] Rob Crabbe she like
what her biggest crime is like being too
in love with him
know also and then when she found out
that he was like texting on the met the
cast members and like he's like thirsty
hits on all the red carpet once
use her for her fame but like doesn't
want to be famous because of her yep
no he's a thirst month sir general I
can't and I can't like now he's ruined
amber Valletta not that I've never seen
anything she's in it I thought she was I
said she was at the Mecca you're like a
merciful Etta's there no why who is she
I know her from revenge but apparently
she's like a really famous model like
back in the day supermodel she's a
supermodel I don't believe that well
he's a super douche okay
that is our Vanderpump rules recap now
we are gonna cut to a small break and
bring out Vinny G from Jersey Shore the
key to Guido I don't know why I'm having
so much trouble saying cuido we talk we
don't it's a Jeff Lee thumb type thing
if you have questions forbid anything
come on YouTube Chris you oh and also
through through a look if you have any
questions for Vinny go to comment on
Instagram comment on YouTube we will be
watching and we're really excited to
break down what's going on with Jersey
Shore so I'm so excited see you in a sec
we'll see you in a sec
you
hello we are back with someone who's
been a really requested gas we're really
excited that he's here we're told we
have all of your questions from diagram
and these not good questions actually um
you know him as Vinny G but now you kind
of know Mizuki dope we know please give
it up for Vinny
how you sake why don't me know why
didn't you know why are you and you also
know him as a man who changed Ben's life
and ruin Chloe
ruined my life and changed Ben Ben's
life because Ben as you guys know was on
keto and if you don't know he was really
inspired by the keto Guido
he was only inspired only inspired by
the Queen Aikido Guido and he is um so
annoying like it's next level and it's
ruining my life so yeah but he does it
weird he does he thank you I'm gonna get
wrong is he I don't know it might be I
mean is he just eating like tubs of mayo
there's a lot of mayo a lot of cheese
but like no onions like I don't get it
like well here's the thing so if he was
having like a very high sugary
carbohydrate diet and then he just
switched to Mayo he's probably gonna
lose a lot of weight yeah because of
that first initial shock to your body
yeah I'm like 15 pounds yeah you know
but that that's not gonna last like once
you start like really getting into shape
it's your way of life yeah eating mayo
and and cheese it's so disgusting my
house smells absolutely horrible
horrible your shirt says recovering
Carbajal like yeah how long have you
been twins in ketosis I'm honestly not
always in ketosis that's kind of like a
I'm just like when Ben was on it like
three days and he was like he smelled so
bad like no we got into bed am like you
stink of go shower the worst be I was
eating and I was so excited he was like
that means I'm in ketosis like it's like
great news like I think he doesn't like
it it's crazy like I don't I don't like
follow it like that like I think people
have a misconception because there's
like cults on Instagram about it and I'm
here to like say that like I'm not part
of those I say the word keto because
it's easy for people to understand it
gets to the point sort of like the
natural eating low carb whole food we
you know that doesn't run it doesn't so
yeah everyone doesn't roll off the
tongue
but ketosis something you might be in
you might not be in just depending on if
you're having a good week if you're
eating fat but like you know I don't
know like once like if I'm hungover like
I'll have some sweet potatoes yeah which
were like horrible really cuz those are
like heaven to somebody potato oh my god
I'm like this is not even a real potato
yeah
and I imagine it was super difficult to
maintain ketosis while in Miami drinking
pizza well the great thing about keto is
you can drink pretty much a lot I mean
again like I follow this kind of like I
just try to eat naturally and like so if
I'm having drinks they're just gonna be
like a natural like a natural vodka
natural wasn't very worried but just
like at least amount of ingredients as
possible yeah so I'll just have like
jameson on the rocks or vodka soda I get
drunk really quick yeah that's that and
I don't you know it's I'm not taking it
as many sugary calories right and then
you get less hungover but you also can't
eat like a bagel so like yeah pizza
thing right you eating the cheese was so
funny
yeah it's so real and how much weight
have you lost I've lost around like 50
pounds since I've not and I tell people
too the impressive thing isn't the
amount of weight that I lost because I
lost that in a couple of months you know
it's it's that I found something that I
it's been off for like four year three
years Wow
so it's something I could do for the
rest of my life yeah cuz that was always
my problem stain yeah it wasn't getting
thin I can't always be like I'm going to
the gym these three months I'm gonna eat
grilled chicken and broccoli and I'm
gonna get skinny but now like I'm like
that's not like yeah this is like yeah
an awesome lifestyle so can you believe
that like you're here now
like backup right here no like it's just
like in in life like growing up like
Jersey Shore was everything like truly
like it defined I dress up a Snuggie for
Halloween like it was just like such a
part of like our growing and just like
the culture it is a phenomenon yeah I
always say you came on yes you came in
she came into my podcast and like I was
ready to interview her I'd never met you
cuz all I saw was rinsed
yeah and you had like a list of 20
questions don't see Grammy like like a
meeting Mariah Carey and better you were
very ahead of the times with your
podcast you so loved your podcast no I'm
starting a new one you should yeah okay
so now we're back in Miami and tell us
about like the genesis like when you got
the call yeah well the answer the
question like that I'm here now yes we
are like when you do a show that big
that was on for so long you always kind
of have this thing in the back of your
head like are we gonna do it again like
you always have like that full house yes
yeah mentality of like you know it's
gonna it's gonna happen again one day we
don't no way but we're gonna reunite and
I'm sure every interview you did you got
that question every interview when you
guys came back together
every second of the day you know so I
kind of always knew but I always thought
like it would be a different production
company maybe a different network a
different format little did I know that
Sally a name thing are you happy about
that like I am it is tough like we're
not the same people we used to be that
could be like come take us away for two
months like I have like bills and [ __ ]
yeah like I don't have a computer there
and I'm like I have to pay my mortgage
that's kind of tough but like as far as
just the formula and the recipe it works
yeah
look you know like I think everyone was
kind of skeptical so it's like you're
not gonna be bringing girls home most of
the people are like married having kids
just like what is it gonna be like and
it was never really about that it's just
like you guys are hilarious
right that's why I told people too
because I had a girlfriend on this
season I told people like if you watch
the show yeah I brought home girls once
in a while but like certain seasons like
that wasn't what it was about how many
girls can you see walking out the next
morning right you know like I mean I
guess sometimes some funny interactions
but they still happen yes whether you
have a girlfriend or not yeah but so do
you still have a girlfriend not right
now no hang on that's very sad sorry do
you wish you were single in my grave no
because like I just said like I had no
interest in like an you're in the club
and stuff and especially in that
environment you're not even talking to
real people if anyone's around the
cameras they're just like like it's like
annoying get out of my face right girl
I'm watching from the beginning and now
I'm in Florence and it's really
interesting to watch I like first two
seasons like it was just like a bunch of
kids on the Jersey Shore
but then as you guys progressed and got
more popular like people around the
shore knew who you were
mm-hmm and it was like when you guys
would even Carmen like you were getting
paparazzi and like in Miami also it's
like that's so crazy and now you guys
are like everyone knows who you are
everyone knows the show do you think
it's like change the way you guys
interact on the show just like going to
restaurants no it's weird it kind of
like came full circle and that's what
makes this show good now is that there
were seasons where I don't want to say
we got cocky with it well some of us
might have liked the situation right of
course yeah I'm not I'm gonna try to
play it off like we're so humble no but
like in that environment you know we
have a hundred security guards around us
like you said parades of people yeah
around we still always like our
production company always made us go
into the real clubs yeah like in Seaside
there's no VIP tables you know but we
are there was some kind of barrier
between us but now we almost feel like
we're filming the first season again
because I don't want to say that like
people don't know who we are they do but
it's a different demographic out there
the kids in the clubs were young when
Toby first came on and we're like more
humble about it like we don't yeah [ __ ]
now sounds like I need to roll around
and have like three guys with me and now
like walk to the bar get a drink like
it's annoying if people are in our face
like the phones make it a noise but
we're like we don't give a [ __ ] about
that I know so funny how you guys
comment on how that clubs have changed
since you what we're in Seaside and like
how the music people don't dance anymore
they just like stand yeah I mean that
was Jenni's kind of thing
yeah people dance I guess it depends on
like on where you go but yeah now
everyone's just well we did it to her
point we didn't have any social media
right yeah I just had Twitter and it's
interesting how like the video of Ron in
the club like hey is it part of the
storyline now because yeah and we didn't
have the thorn so we were like calling
Lauren like what's out there we get a
phone call she really was like we're
like in jail and you guys need Instagram
on the duck phone I know
exactly so you kind of went viral when
you did that knocking down the door it
is so funny how did you come up with
that um I don't know like I feel like
I've been doing ice it's like I'm a
little kid I feel like family parties
and I feel
I've done it like on the show before but
for some reason that was like a big
thing and I had no idea was gonna go
viral like that it's so funny they
remixed it with the yodeling kid I
thought was amazing yeah I then like
Steve Aoki he wanted me to post it
because like he had a song and he
coincided it to that let's go the power
the power is Jersey Shore have you seen
flour Bama sure I have seen like one
episode of to what he just because I
think it's totally different I think
that's like comparing the real world to
Jersey yeah that's a different you know
that what makes us like special and
different is like where we're from like
we're like aliens up in the Northeast
like you know like the tri-state area
and the rest of the country is kind of
like the same yes like even like
southern southerners and you would have
thought that her in like California like
you would notice a difference but it's
like all right like white people like
whatever but then like you put like a
Guido somewhere and it's like what yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] is this person you
know so we always gonna remain that like
no one looked like Paulie now anywhere
yeah you guys really like shaped Guido
culture honestly we came on late to that
like beforehand
there were shows like growing up gaudy
remember that jerseylicious
jerseylicious was I think at the same
time but growing a body was like the
first reality show ever
like that that fad came and went like
you know and then when they were casting
the show cuz I'm like the anti Guido I
was like there's no more Guido's I don't
know where they're gonna find another
Guido like that these people are from
California and they still have this
warped could you know misconception of
the Jersey Shore yeah and lo and behold
I walk in the house and I'm like they
found the last [ __ ] Pauly D with the
blowup iPhone the last of the mojitos
because he has like a blowout I'm like
there's no one on earth that has a blowy
steel as a well that still has it it
kind of like stop for a second then he
went back so who do you think has
changed the most since the first season
well everyone has changed like their
lives have changed like their mom's name
yeah
Snooki like she makes like chicken
cutlets yeah like that's a good I never
had her chicken cause I'm Kido you know
so chicken it has it's breaded fried but
like I'm sure they're good and she makes
like and you know she makes dinner for a
family like that that was unheard of
back in the day like she could barely I
remember open a jar of pickles
but she's exactly the same in the sense
of I feel like in life we all go full
circle where we have to like how well do
you 25 yeah so like you're still in that
in that zone I feel where like you might
be like I have to be cool now because
like I'm in my 20s and but then like it
you just throw it all out the window and
you're like get drunk and act like an
idiot like you know that's what we're
all doing that's not like you know we
put down the ego and everyone's like the
same about who changed the mic though oh
yeah has changed for the positive and
it's funny because I feel like in the
first couple episodes he wasn't getting
that much shine because he's got like
partying like a crazy filmin anymore but
now everyone's starting to like love him
like we do because in little spots he's
like given all these like inspirational
yeah Claudia is obsessed I'm gonna cuss
him I think like yeah yes he was a
villain but his role in like creating
your guyses like vernacular was like so
important he's just so funny and I just
really like him he's always tell people
he's still like a weirdo yeah it's still
like doing the same matrix crazy things
like yeah he still creates little words
and stuff he's just not high anymore
right yeah that's good that's great
who's changed the least probably Paulie
yeah yeah just he's like a robot yes he
doesn't sleep he just DJ's laughs smiles
yells danced and that's it yeah he's I
could never do that so I want to talk
about Snooki because like so like I said
right now I'm watching season four
advisor in Florence but I'm also
watching Jersey where like she's married
at like noon she won't talk to you
and I really ship you guys like I really
wish like I think in another world you
would have worked out this is stupid I
know and like I'm sick I'm still like
I'm not giving up like I really think
there's something there
I think you should give up but I
understand what you mean like in
world yeah and like what do you think it
was didn't really work out there so so I
had like two one-night stands with
Snooki right yes it's like not that much
but like it was more like an emotional
connection like a promise with you like
about like how how I really like her and
it was great yes oh my god
I maybe one day just it was bad time
okay okay no but like Nicole and I are
never like I really genuinely she's
hilarious like she's I called them and
now her Deena like in the house I called
them my therapy pugs yeah
they're like you like pugs yeah like if
you had two little pugs and you're
having a bad day and they like jumped on
you like wouldn't your days instantly
better yeah so like that's what they are
they're like my little pugs in the house
so like Snooki like I could like look at
her and she'll calms me down
yeah because she's just a mess did you
love her so much no oh yeah like I said
a friend but then like and that that
connection was always there just like
you know we just are friends with each
other and then you know we're like 20 20
something-year-old
from kids in a house and like I was I
don't know I'm a savage to it like all
right whatever you wanna have sex let's
do it
I just and that's all it was Claudia I'm
sorry situation just got engaged yes
we're very happy for help we're so happy
for her do you think everyone's gonna be
invited to the wedding of course
Sam oh good yeah I mean Mike like his MO
in life now is to not have like grudges
it's part of like his recovery yeah you
know what I mean so he he's done he's
the wrong one to ask that like he'll
invite Mike someone who killed his dog
to the wedding you know what I mean so
um them off to you okay did you tip the
barber who missed up who mess every base
or something
yeah do you know like we're it wasn't
one of those haircuts where like in the
moment like you just worry so let's
clarify that cuz I want on like a
conversation on Twitter recently cuz
what the thing is like when these shows
air you just kind of like let them air
and then like in the moment people
chatter and then like if you want to
address something like Oh like I need to
address this yeah but we don't we don't
have a phone or anything and like we
don't pick a barber the production
production
for us like they give us a book they
like look up like barbershop yellow
pages yeah and as you guys know you guys
are women you pamper yourselves yeah
like just like I can't just walk into
any eyebrow lady no you know what if I
know right it changes your whole look
yeah
so that's what I was doing in that in
that scenario and then I was like all
right still give him the benefit of the
doubt he's a barber does a barbershop
could be yeah then he said he was
cutting a year and I'm like okay a year
like now now we're like really on thin
service the so nervous because if I get
a bad haircut on a random Tuesday I'll
grow back in a couple days it'll be fine
yeah I'm in front of millions of people
it's my one shot Jim to be on TV
Beyonce watches Jersey Shore does she
she did have a good haircut in front of
Beyonce like our fade is everything like
if you're one of your eyebrows was
crooked I you know so so then I gave him
the benefit of doubt and then even still
in the moment like they edited it like I
showed you like because it at one point
I say I don't like it yeah but with the
mirror with a mirror for my face and
then like they put in a part like later
on I don't like it I didn't say it the
guy you know totally and that look I
don't mean but I had figured since they
put the merit of your mouth in the
moment I'm like cool thanks man like not
happy but like cool thanks here's your
here's your boy
yeah and then I left and like it's a
reality show right and I don't like keep
things secret and like sign to Pauly
like I don't like my haircut I'm like I
don't like my haircut let's go find
another bar back and all of a sudden I
was demonized as the meanest person no I
thought it was me no just Department I
don't like I didn't do that so I guess
if you take that part out maybe people
wouldn't have and what which the part
that I didn't do out then maybe yeah no
you were fine the rest of the time like
it was obviously you were uncomfortable
but like that's not your fault
everyone's uncomfortable during a
haircut yeah even if I did sit I don't
like it though
I'm not that type like I won't ever like
send my food back or I'm just not
obviously passive you and your face
then my friends literally full fully
eating meals back everything he's turned
in artichoke once he was like it's not
juicy enough remember hey there where's
the kitchen it was people it wasn't
babies no by the way our food totally
gets bit and all the time I will go out
with him because I'm embarrassed
oh yeah like even if you weren't you
were weren't passive and you're like hey
I don't like it like I don't know I feel
like barbers and people and beauty are
too quick to like they say yes to
everything yeah like if you walked in
you're like oh I want to do my eyebrows
like I have a specific thing like she
can be starting that day yes you can beg
up I got this I'm a professional I'm
like if you don't do a good job like I'm
sorry like that's your job
totally unfortunately this guy was on
like Jersey Shore like the biggest TV or
Thursday listen he actually gave a good
haircut for someone that has been
cutting a year oh yeah you know I can't
do it favor I have a question because
when I was watching the episode where
Ronnie brought home those girls and that
one girl like got blackout and like
throw up on the couch I was shocked to
my core cuz like I feel like I know that
girl like she went to University of
Miami like I could have known her you
know Nene and like she got out and look
she was like like numb and like her body
wasn't moving she was like never like
Snooki was holding me and now that girl
like it's her claim to fame on Instagram
have you seen sure like do you have you
spoken her no so that girl that girl
when we were on the show she was saying
like like okay so girls come back right
and then like you don't know who was a
fan who who is just random who's like
everyone knows what it is yeah usually
it's like you know what it is but you're
not like a die-hard you know name only
once in a while like a die-hard like
infiltrates used to be grenades and now
it's done yeah now yeah exactly so like
she was a die-hard oh yeah and she knew
where we were gonna be she like made it
a point yeah like I I'm like I hate that
I'm talking about this we're gonna
change it back soon okay yeah but I just
want to say it she'll be on her she was
saying like back that back then she was
saying she was most likely voted to be
on Jersey Shore so like that whole thing
was like a calculator right like she
made it I'm Jersey Shore and then that
was that was her moment of
there's these days is out of control
yeah but it's so funny like you you got
on you finally made it and then you were
like a spaz about something you drink to
my of course and you black out any Botox
yeah it was bad but we all helped her I
mean like production like did a good job
like you don't see that part more like
you know production Misook he was being
helpful too yeah yeah it was wild like
I've never seen anything like that him
and like I drink a lot like all the time
saying I mean I've been their best line
of the whole season it was like [ __ ]
I'm Snookie I've been there yeah like
you know oh my god it's just a full
circle we've come yeah he's not taking
care of the girls right I don't want to
know if you guys are so close with Danny
from the shore store oh I mean close as
in Halleck we don't go to the top so
there's like holidays like I've been to
UM seaside over the years I go there
like I get like cheese balls yeah
they're amazing I'll go stop it like
because I don't really go to like the
mad pop in places like crowded so see
sighs like it's funny it's like you go
there's like a couple like old trashy
Jersey people there and I'm just like
drinking with you I would go visit him
once in a while what do you think about
Sammy's decision not to join like do you
think that she made the right decision I
don't want to say she made the right or
the wrong decision I understand where
she's coming from but just for like the
money and opportunity I would have liked
her just make it work yeah you know what
I mean like because there are things
like I hate about the show like it show
gives me like crazy anxiety and like
depression hmm PTSD like the list goes
on but like you know for the money and
for the opportunity like I'll make it
work of course you know like especially
at this age yes like I had like again
like mortgages and and I'm not saying I
do anything for money cuz yeah I'd
assert and that's why I left back then
because at a certain point like money is
just not worth like your sanity but um
I'm in like a better place like where
like it's gonna suck mm-hmm and I accept
it but like not everything should be
easy
yeah you know what I mean it's right I
think she could've went through it in
the same kind of thing you know
yeah but now it's like I said I'm
rewatching and like I'm watching the
whole genesis of Sam and Ronnie and like
as like I was watching us like a
fourteen-year-old girl and now I'm
watching us like a 23 year old woman and
like it
very clear that like Ronnie is abusive
and like their whole relationship is
like super manipulative and like I
really despise him and now we're seeing
that happen all over again like when I
watch back I'm like I can't believe
we're still talking about Ron and Sam
and like we're still talking about Ron
and Sam today yeah I mean I will say
that that's a little bit of editing
because we all spoke about Sammy like
it's we don't have phones we don't have
anything we're just sitting in a room
looking at walls and cameras and it's
gonna come up that we talk about Sam but
of course like what are they gonna hone
in on yeah Ronnie talking about Sam I
mean so yeah he could have like been
more conscientious of just like don't
say her name is all you know what she
did it but in his defense like you're
not really thinking like that when
you're there you're just talking yeah
you know we don't know what's gonna be
on the show later yeah that's true but
yeah until for tomorrow night tomorrow
night yeah into some trouble I I don't I
didn't see the episode they're not like
they don't show them to us till
unfortunately I wish I did you watch
your life I don't we usually we watch
earlier in the day because like if we
have interviews and stuff like we talked
about it but sometimes I've watched it
live I'm hoping not to watch this one
live yeah it's the first one where like
it looks like I'm doing something bad
yeah which I don't I mean I'm making the
same things don't want people to know
yeah but I didn't see it yet and
Ronnie's baby mama comes to the house
yes yeah yeah so I guess they're gonna
show that that she comes and visits do
any of the kids visit um no the kids oh
that would be wildly innovative well
that's the thing to everyone thought
that like I thought that that when we do
a reunion it was gonna be like family
everybody I thought families are was
there yeah like family and then like you
know like kind of like housewives like
they use like kids around in the
background and stuff but this was like
nope extracting you from your families
and putting you in this house I get
drunk same thing that's meeting so if
you for season two if you could go
anywhere where would you want to be
because you have a confirmed season two
yes we do um I don't know like I want to
say Jersey like just because like when
we go to these other places like it's
tough like we're not going to Miami like
a normal person yes right every place we
go has to be cleared by camera
what clubs are you guys going to in
Miami yeah like three clubs like Makai
eleven oh and what does it mean yeah but
then that's it then like Clevelander
same three same like we have like a book
of places that are cleared and that's it
we could we could pick from there oh
here's my question jersey to answer like
yeah everything is like easy they're
like you know we walk to the store I can
get like bacon and eggs like right next
door on the boardwalk it's much more in
Miami it's like you have to like clear
like ten production places to get like
breakfast you know does MTV P for your
guys's tables um yes and no they started
like sometimes they did that but they're
not like that's like a gift like they're
not likely to do that no but I do Ally
will always have a table yeah so this
year they were better at doing that
especially because like certain like mic
that it doesn't drain right I mean it
would just be like me and Pauly like my
bottles every night you know what this I
think the the club's calm a lot yeah
well yeah that makes sense a lot of
sense okay well I don't know cuz like I
didn't I didn't deal yeah yeah like well
it's production company is like a giant
assist yeah you just have to get drunk
for them and fight each other um how was
it to finally have a pool it was awesome
but when went in twice okay well I don't
think production ever like encouraged
the mics yeah cuz like you can't hear
anything and it was never heated it was
heated once I went in but when I did
that yard was the best char we've got
that yard kept me sane yeah like we've
never had a yard like that well when you
guys got to the house everyone was
freaking out about the pool is it why is
he freaking out at the pool they don't
never seen a pool before then I realize
you've never had a pool and see stuff
like those hot tubs yeah we didn't have
time to go in the pool yeah it was so it
was so different this time like because
we only shot in a month and people have
like real lives like so whereas we would
like take like full summers sometimes
yeah and like milk it like now it was
like every single day every second every
every night was like us doing something
is that what you're going to lunch
yeah you guys went from Florence to
Seaside that was crazy yeah that's when
you had your like little moment yes yeah
I would to understand
yeah like I'm like like I think I'm
normal for having that most like a
relatable thing ever I was like when I
get hungover I want to be near nobody
and you're hungover every day and you're
drinking every night you're in the same
houses the same people in different
countries I'm like how are they living
like this and I'm surprised you for the
first one and like nobody had an
experience like that before people had
experiences like that like I'm prone to
like having anxiety like I've had it's
like from when our little kids are like
what I do is like the worst thing I mean
they were like you could not go straight
no nothing and it will show to you like
the drinkie filming yeah that's you
couldn't construct a worse place for
yeah someone with anxiety bright lights
no phone you know people watching you
alcohol no sleep you know your physical
physic physical activity is just none
people watching you all the time the
unknown you never know like what
surprises around the corner but I deal
with it pretty well you know back then
like I started like feeling like very
just like there's a lot of like tipping
that wasn't like any anxiety like
exactly it was more like just like a
depression and like it wouldn't go away
and it scared me and now I'm in a place
where and you know this I'm saying this
because it helps people yeah you can
feel like I'm not I'm not saying like
I'm in a place now where like I don't
have those feelings because it's normal
to have those feelings but like
sometimes you have to just be like it's
okay to have those feelings and if you
spend like a month of having those
feelings like you're still fine it's
gonna pass like what I mean so that's
how like I've learned to deal with it
back then that was a mistake I made I'm
like I'm having these feelings I need to
go home right you know now stead of like
working through it yeah like not like
just just accepting it it's like you
know what this sucks I have it sucked I
wish it wasn't like this yeah but you
know but it's probably a lot easier in
the queen bed and like in a much nicer
house the house was like it was nicer
but like it was all like renovation so
we're so like the bathrooms were out of
control dude I hate [ __ ] I hate
shitty then yeah that's what better
makes a breaker look I got an apartment
or house I like although bathrooms on
Instagram I'm serious
Queen beds like would you have done a
those a twin yeah we don't we have no
control over that
what's a house is that you can't like
what good thing about Queens okay so you
have to wrap up but if you want to
follow along with the Kido journey you
can follow the key to Guido or kita you
know well my main page is Vinny
Guadagnino yeah and then my douchey
Fitness page is Quito Guido it's really
good it's funny odd for been for betting
yes I wish Ben was here I know people do
a one-on-one to go on Aikido date I need
to show him I think I'm like really show
this is definitely doing it he's making
me throw up
I just lost weight so he's doing
something good yeah well most people
they just cut out all the carbs process
stuff and they changed I think people
that go I know we're wrapping off sorry
but people that like go vegan to there
like for any diet they go on like
automatically the change it's just a
change of like eliminating soda and
chips symbol that's gonna make them lose
it but this is like the only thing that
I feel is very sustainable for a long
period of time
oh I agree well congrats on the success
they show it's on tomorrow night yeah
Thursday maybe I get him oh my I'm gonna
it's so it's the worst you go on Twitter
during the show I live sweet oh yeah but
usually I'm like I'm like like a saint
on the show yeah but last year last week
like I was a demon because of like I
don't like my haircut yeah
so this week I'm just gonna be like just
it's all downhill from yeah I'm just
gonna get hung thanks for tuning in make
sure you're following the morning show
us on Facebook YouTube and then the
podcast app we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
so we'll be back tomorrow we'll see you
then
you